[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein hefeteig rezept und
zwar weil ich diese süße hebel brot
backen
von außen sieht es gar nicht so
spektakulär aus aber bloß tun
ich habe von innen und jede scheibe
sieht anders aus also egal wo man halt
anschneidet und es wird immer ein
anderes boot man wohl ich sag das
prosieben
ich hab das einfach den hefeteig mit
kakaopulver eingefärbt und dadurch
entsteht eben dieses muster und die
herstellung ist echt super einfach ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
hefeteig für den hefeteig brauche ich 15
gramm hefe zwei esslöffel warmes wasser
60 g zucker 1 eigelb einen halben
teelöffel salz 180 milliliter milch 400
gramm mehl und 80 gramm flüssige butter
und außerdem brauche ich zum einfärben
drei esslöffel kakao und zwei esslöffel
milch und einen halben esslöffel cargo
und einen esslöffel mensch zuerst
versucht jetzt die hefe mit dem wasser
und mit dem zucker so kann sich die hefe
wirklich super auflösen und dann geht es
gleich in der schüssel weiter kommen die
zutaten in die große schüssel lebt auch
die restlichen zutaten rein also salz
eigelb die milch das mehl und auch die
flüssige butter und den teig könnt ihr
natürlich auch mit den händen verkneten
so geht's aber ein bisschen einfacher
und schneller für mich und jetzt darauf
einen hefeteig nähten und es dauerte
etwa fünf bis sieben minuten
und während der teig knetet kann ich
schon mal kakaopulver milch berühren die
brauche ich nämlich gleich zum einfärben
daher einmal die große menge mit der
großen menge milch und dann auch gleich
die kleine menge milch mit der kleinen
menge cacau
[Musik]
so sieht der hefeteig jetzt aus da ist
richtig schön verknetet und klebt auch
nicht falls ihr das gefühl habt er ist
bis hin zu klebrig dann gibt einfach
noch ein esslöffel mehl dazu aber
eigentlich passt das echt zu wirklich
wunderbar ich werde jetzt meine
arbeitsfläche bisher mit back trends
gray mit welchem tag halbieren
die eine hälfte bleibt dem nicht weiß
das heißt die kann ich schon mal zu
einer kugel formen und die andere hälfte
halbiere ich nochmal und die werden
jetzt eingefärbt mit dem kakao das heißt
ihr könnt es entweder mit der hand ein
ketten oder mit der maschine nicht es
jetzt einfach zurück und gebe zwar erst
mal die kleine menge kaka mit rein und
da kann es sein dass ein bisschen
klebriger wird und hier einfach nur mal
zwei drei esslöffel mehl dazugeben ist
unter einer wird jetzt bisschen heller
eingefärbt und andere schön dunkel
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die drei aus und das ist
wirklich schöne farben und vor allem
schöne farbabstufungen und die werde ich
jetzt eine stunde bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen zum aufgehen
die tage sind jetzt gut aufgegangen und
jetzt funktioniere ich daraus jeweils
acht teile das heißt in dem einen strang
halb ihr ihn dann nochmal halbieren und
nochmal halbieren und das macht jetzt
mit allen
[Musik]
den dunkelsten teig den vor mich jetzt
zu einem strang
dann nehme ich den schlüssel helleren
der wir doch zu einem strang geformt
wird dann aber ausgerollt und nehme ich
habe um den dunklen herum gelegt wenn es
ein bisschen klebt nehmen wir einfach
bock trance prey und dieser wird dann
wiederum in den hellen eingepackt
jetzt habe ich alle geformt und jetzt
könnt ihr euch zb eine kastenform nehmen
entweder eine große oder eine kleinere
und kleinere damit das brot auch richtig
schön voluminös wird das wird kurz
eingesprüht
mit back trends brille und jetzt lege
ich die einzelnen stränge einfach hier
rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den teig abdecken und
dann noch mal für eine halbe stunde bis
stunde aufgehen lassen bis es sich schön
verdoppelt hat jetzt ist das leopard
richtig schön aufgegangen und jetzt kann
es gebacken werden
[Musik]
der helfer kuchen mit nach dem backen
direkt mit etwas butter bestrichen so
bleibt da richtig schön weich und saftig
und so sieht jetzt aus ich muss ja
bereits gestellt
es fällt nicht schwer das zu sagen
möchte ich schalte ich habe man extra
kind im teig weil sie derzeit noch
leckerer machen wollt nehmt gewann
händler extra end
jetzt könnt ihr hier zum beispiel lernen
curt drauf machen ja sowieso hefeteig
mit klemmen geworden weil das ist ja so
jetzt einfach nur etwa rudi sohm
rosinenbrot ohne rosinen gerissen keine
rosinen und ist es halt nicht so süß
jetzt kann man zum beispiel zum
frühstück zubereitet wurden probiert ich
wird halt wissen butter drauf streichen
manche mögen vielleicht nutella
unterbrochen
ja es hat nichts davon musste aber ich
finde jetzt auch mit lemon gehört ganz
lecker oder einfach so von einem kaffee
oder cappuccino und cool oder und
richtig einfach gemacht und prinzip kann
man ja auch am lebensmittelfarben nehmen
und das ganze pink und grün und blau
machen aber so finde ich echt richtig
schön einfach mit kaká eingesetzt
und falls ihr das rezept nach lesen
wollt geht auch cds - blog.de da steht
alles noch mal ganz genau ich wünsche
euch viel spaß beim nachbacken bin auf
eure leopardenmuster gespannt und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
toll dass meine fragen wieder kalt ist
zwei minuten 12
[Musik]